A couple lessons back we've talked about
how their various types of request that
you can make to the server.
And so far, we've talk
specifically about get request and
then have seen how to use
them in our examples.
Earlier in this lesson, we mentioned
that we'd also be implementing what's
called the post request to add a feature
to our my favorite movies app.
Now, it's time to look
at this in more detail.
A POST request, as you may recall
is a request where the client
submits data to a web server for
processing.
The data that's sent is enclosed in
the message body of the request,
which can then be processed
to a specified resource.
We'll use a post request to favorite or
unfavorite a movie in
the Favorite Movies list of our app.
So let's go back to the movie
database's API documentation.
By searching for the word favorite on
the API page, I found this method,
which allows me to add or
remove a movie to an account's favorite
list, which seems like what we want.
Now we'll click on the post banner
to open up the right-hand panel,
which has information on
how to set up this request.
Here at the top, we see the URL that
the POST request should be made to.
In other words, that's where the
resource we want to update is located.
Now, this section underneath that
is titled request should give us
the information that we need
to create this in code.
These little drop down menus give
us a few additional options.
Let's keep this setting as production
and this one appears to be
a language setting, so let's set
it to Swift and see what we get.
Cool, this looks like stuff we can use
even if we don't know exactly what
it is yet.
But before we dig into it,
I feel like we missed something.
What was this over here at the top
before we changed to Swift?
Headers, we haven't
talked about that yet.
So headers are actually a part of
an HTTP request along with the URL and
the message body, they allow us to
supply additional parameters that
specify how the request should operate.
Here we see that for this request,
two headers are supplied.
The accept header field allows us to
specify which content types will accept
in response.
In our case,
we want to accept JSON as our response.
The content type header field let's
us specify what kind of content we're
sending in the body.
In other words,
what format our data is in,
so that the server knows what's coming
and can determine how to parse it.
There are many other types
of HTTP header fields.
A list of them is linked
in the instructor notes.
Awesome.
Now, we understand what
these headers are for.
Let's go back to this code and see if
we can understand what's happening.
So this already looks a bit familiar, we
did this when making our other requests.
Here, we are creating the URL and
then using NSMuteableURLRequest
to make the request from the URL.
Now these lines are new,
but if you look at them,
we already know what they're doing.
Request.HTTPMethod = POST,
we're setting our request
method type to be of type post,
then request.addvalue application/json
for HTTP header field accept.
This is just the code we need
to set up our two header fields.
Now if we look back at what was
displayed when we had the language
settings set to raw, there was
what looked to be a bit of JSON.
"Media_type", "movie", "media_id",
550, "favorite", true.
This seems like the information
we'd want to give the server, but
with our own values specified.
So it looks like this little JSON piece
is here to show us what we should
be sending.
Let's look back at the Swift
code we're provided.
Request.HTTPBody =.
So it looks like here's where
we want to supply that data,
the data that we want to post.
This is where we should fill in
what movie we're talking about and
whether we want favorite to be true or
not.
Those can be variables that
we can put in our code.
The rest of this is actually
all stuff we've seen before.
Just getting the sessions,
making the task, etc.
We already know how to do that.
So when you make this POST
request in your app in Xcode,
you should be able to copy over
most of the spoiler plate code and
only really need to change a few things.